E aí
[Música]
se você acha que falar sobre abandono
parental é um problema
se Sim esse é o problema Por mais que
ele vem sendo cada vez mais frequente EA
realidade demais famílias o abandono
parental aí não tá boa e por isso
precisa ser discutido
e o abandona acontece quando um dos Pais
para dizer uma de suas obrigações ele
pode acontecer de cinco maneiras
diferentes a primeira ela abandono
afetivo ou emocional que acontece quando
um dos Pais para de dar atenção carinho
e afeto a criança isso faz com que ela
se sentia extremamente largada deixar
ela de lado como se ela não importasse o
segundo é o financeiro quando os pais
param de dar o apoio financeiro a
criança e isso é para onde comprar
brinquedos roupas e comida
é o quarto é intelectual Quando se é
proibido e é vetado o ensino básico a
criança
a e agora desmistificando naquela idade
aqui para aconteceu abandono parental o
pai ou a mãe tem que efetivamente sair
da vida da criança temos o do acho que
esse sim é quando o pai ou a mãe pára de
participar do dia da criança isso pode
acontecer com ele se mudando ou parando
de buscar ela em caso de divórcio
e o quinto é o do idoso que é quando há
uma inversão de papéis por conta da
idade de seus pais a criança passa a ter
que cuidar deles e não o oposto
agora vocês podem estar se perguntando a
Juliana o que que leva um pai ou uma mãe
abandonar sua criança porque realmente é
uma coisa meio absurda você pensar
e as principais causas abandono parental
são primeira cena a condição financeira
às vezes por não ter uma boa condição
Financeira ou por outros fatores
externos os pais optam por abandonar a
criança para que esta tem uma melhor
condição de vida como a gente pode ver
na segunda estão com a cena de mães
dando seus filhos à soldados americanos
o segundo e uma das e a principal é o
divórcio depois do divórcio muitas vezes
um dos pais não se sente mais uma
obrigação de participar da vida da
criança o que é uma expressão totalmente
falsa porque não é porque você quebrou
os laços com seu cônjuge que você também
vai quebrar com essa criança e as suas
próprias relações familiares as vezes
por não ter tido um bom exemplo quando
era criança isso acaba refletindo em sua
relação com seu filho
e o abandono parental tem diversas
consequências da saúde mental da criança
podendo senão bem
acompanhado refletir até sua vida adulta
eu queria começar dizendo que cada
pessoa uma pessoa e cada história uma
história Então o que acontece com uma
pessoa as consequências na vida de uma
pessoa não vão ser da outra mas as
principais causas abandono são
consequências do abandono são a primeira
e mais óbvia o medo de abandono quando o
porto seguro da criança a estabilidade
dela sai da vida dela Isso mostra que
qualquer outra pessoa pode fazer o mesmo
e que seria muito mais fácil para amigos
e colegas
abandonarem a segunda e copio abaixo de
estima e novo curso uma coisa tão fora
da caixinha uma coisa que a gente nunca
vai imaginar que aconteça o primeiro
pensamento que vem na cabeça dessa
criança é Ah se eu tivesse feito uma
coisa diferente e talvez meu pai não
tivesse me abandonado se eu tivesse
falado alguma coisa diferente talvez
minha mãe não tivesse saído da minha
vida isso também vem com elas em ASP
popularizar-se que são aquelas pessoas
que vão sair da sua o porto para agradar
outro e também com a dificuldade de
dizer ou não
eu fui capaz de criar Em capacidade de
criar vínculos eu quero dizer
dificuldade de manter relacionamentos em
geral por conta desse medo de abandono O
que é muitas vezes visto como ciúmes mas
é mais que isso na maioria das vezes não
é um medo do seu amigo de outros amigos
e sem o medo dele te trocar por esses
outros amigos foi comprovado que
crianças que sofreram algum tipo de
abandonar Sim foi no seu mais propícias
a desenvolver de transtornos mentais
como toc ansiedade depressão e agora
para consequências não são óbvias nós
temos a a falta de controle como a vida
dessa criança está totalmente fora do
controle dela ela não consegue controlar
quem vai ficar na casa dela quem vai
falar com ela se os pais dela vão
amarela e isso muitas vezes leva o
controle excessivo de outra parte isso
pode vir na comida levando a transtornos
alimentares ou em coisas mais fúteis
como tempo é porque ela não pode
controlar o sentimento dos Pais em
relação a ela mas ela pode controlar
quanto tempo vai levar para cada
atividade do dia dela e todo o contorno
excessiva é prejudicial à saúde mental
EA busca por validação Nós seres humanos
a inevitável que a gente faça tudo por
uma validação externa Então você estuda
para ir bem numa prova e os seus pais e
professores falarem Parabéns você é uma
boa pessoa você é um bom aluno você é
inteligente ou você faz um trabalho
social para que a sociedade te veja como
uma boa pessoa e quando não se tem essa
validação em casa é inevitável que essa
criança vai procurar ela em outros
lugares em paz de amigos e colegas e
professores ou até mesmo com a validação
acadêmica onde as consequências que são
efeitos colaterais muitas vezes em junto
com abandono parental são o abuso mental
alienação parental EA manipulação
percebam que eu coloquei as três juntas
Porque elas estão muito interligadas e
muitas vezes acontecem ao mesmo tempo e
o abuso mental acontece em todo e
qualquer relação
cuja uma das partes tem como objetivo
machucar outra com meio djinga Mentos
insultos silêncio como forma de punição
e até mesmo a manipulação alienação
parental acontece quando um dos Pais usa
da manipulação para afastar a criança do
outro manipulando eventos Fatos e
acontecimentos
e existem vários jeitos de se manipular
uma pessoa mas quando a gente fala de
manipulação Mental é mais comum é o gás
clayden que a quando o manipulador usa
da alteração de eventos e acontecimentos
de palavras para seu benefício e isso
pode ser visto com frases como
se você é louca
e isso nunca aconteceu isso é tudo
fantasma da sua cabeça eu estou muito
chateada com essas acusações e ela
arquitetado de uma forma de que você vai
realmente achar que o que a pessoa tá
falando a verdade eu queria ressaltar
que não é porque a família que você tem
que ser Submisso a qualquer tipo de
comportamento manipulador e abusivo
e eu acho que não surpresa que existe
uma grande diferença no que diz respeito
ao número de abandonou paternal e
Maternal no Brasil 5,5 milhões de
certidões de nascimento não tem o nome
do pai e 1,6 milhões de família são
formadas por mim solo eu queria pedir
para que vocês tirem um segundinho para
refletir o porquê que essa diferença
ainda tão grande
e eu refletir e eu cheguei à conclusão
que é porque eu posso do machismo na
sociedade ainda vê o filho como sendo da
mulher o que é mesmo então totalmente
errada porque o pai e a mãe ambos têm os
mesmos direitos e deveres no que diz
respeito à criação da criança Esse é um
pensamento extremamente machista
extremamente arcaico Então a gente tem
que entender que uma coisa gosta muito
de pensar que se precisando de duas
pessoas para fazer uma criança ela não
deve ser criada apenas por uma
e a pandemia mudou a dinâmica de várias
relações familiares nós passamos a
conviver 24 horas por dia com pessoas
que vimos muitas vezes por 54 até mesmo
três essa esse excesso de convivência
pode ter tido tantos resultados
positivos quando resultados negativos na
minha experiência ambos aconteceram
durante a pandemia eu tive relações que
melhoraram e relações que pioraram E
essas relações que pioraram me fizeram
ver minha vida de outra forma ver os
acontecimentos do passado de outra forma
e de uma certa forma reinicializar mas
não como em videogames que você volta do
zero porque não é assim que acontece na
vida a gente não pode esperar tudo o que
aconteceu no passado mas sim olhar para
o passado e ver como que eu podia me
portar diante das coisas que aconteceram
para que eu tirei um proveito melhor
disso Isso me leva o meu próximo tópico
Como superar percebo que eu coloquei
entre aspas porque eu não acho que é uma
coisa que se supera 100 porcento Pense
como não corte Você cortou seu dedo Você
foi no médico ele costurar Ah mas mesmo
assim mesmo curado a cicatriz ainda tá
lá o X da questão é achar como o que que
você tem que fazer para você se sentir
bem em relação a isso e para você ficar
bem Como que aconteceu e de novo como
cada pessoa uma pessoa e cada história é
uma história é inevitável que cada
pessoa vai precisar de coisas diferentes
para melhorar mas eu queria compartilhar
com vocês algumas dicas dica número um
aceitar as vezes a gente não aceita que
aquela coisa realmente aconteceu com
você por não querer que ela tem
acontecido ou por achar que você tá
exagerando fazendo tempestade num copo
d'água mas não se pode curar algo que
não se saiba que está acontecendo
dica número 2 se perdoar com muita aí
fazendo ser porque eu não acho que você
tenha que perdoar outra pessoa para
superar ou você tenha que esperar o
perdão de outra pessoa para superar mas
se perdoar Fundamental e se perdoar de
questões que muitas vezes você nem
imagina que você se culpa
a dica do perdi três entendeu o que
aconteceu Pode parecer bem boba mas se
você realmente não tira um tempo para
refletir no que aconteceu como você se
sente em relação a isso você nunca vai
entender os seus gatilhos o que te faz
se sentir bem o que te faz se sentir mal
Isso é crucial no processo de melhora
dica número 4 dê tempo ao tempo essa
menstruação que eu gosto muito porque a
gente tem que entender que as coisas não
vão acontecer no tempo que a gente quer
e que pode levar um tempo não é eu
instalei meu dedo que tudo que aconteceu
no passado acabou eu sou feliz eu sou
uma nova mulher não pode levar anos
meses e dias e a gente tem que nos
permitir esse tempo a gente tem que nos
permitir sentir tudo Afinal existe certo
e errado que sentimento não é porque
você tá feliz que você tá certo E por
que você tá triste o que você tá feliz
porque você tá triste porque tá errado
todos os sentimentos são válidas e cada
sentimento vai te ensinar uma coisa
diferente
e eu gosto de ver se tudo como uma
escada no começo os degraus são muito
grandes e a gente acha que a gente nunca
vai conseguir subir quê Porque é muito
alto você nunca vai conseguir seu Bic
sua vida acabou mas com o tempo depois
de
respirar fundo e muita tentativa e erro
você sobe o primeiro degrau
eventualmente segundo o terceiro eo
quarto e com o tempo vai ficando mais
fácil porque se sagram diminuindo de
tamanho já que você aprende o que que te
faça sentir bem o que que você precisa
para ficar bem consigo mesmo mas
eventualmente por alguma razão do
destino pode aparecer um degrau grande
de novo e aí quando o pânico volta e
quando você relapsa e tudo bem Ela está
o problema é relapsa e ficar lá porque
você tem que entender aqui é sua vida no
fim do dia você o protagonista da sua
vida se você não se amar e se você não
se priorizar quem vai Oi e a dica número
5 é procure ajuda profissional é só
provavelmente a dica mais importante
palavras não expressam a importância de
ter uma acompanhamento profissional de
médicos terapeutas e psiquiatras ou com
importante isso é importante vai
Minimizar as consequências desse trauma
no futuro e eu sei que para você que tem
uma boa relação comos os seus pais tudo
que eu posso tá falando agora Pode
parecer muito fora da caixinha muito
absurdo mas eu espero que vocês percebam
o quanto andando parental É sério e o
quanto ele precisa ser discutido para
que mais pessoas sintam-se à vontade de
falar sobre o que acontece com elas e
voltando para a tela de reinicializar
eu vou aproveitar a pandemia para não só
reinicializar com os nossos problemas
com os nossos calmas olhar para o
passado de uma forma diferente mas nós
discutir mais sobre problemas que muitas
vezes a gente deixava de lado e se você
se identificou com a minha palestra Eu
espero que você se sinta ouvido e saiba
que você não está sozinho Muito obrigada
a
[Música]